I think the locavore movement is
brilliant and it all makes perfect sense
because we went from kind of in the
fifties and sixties in America it was
all about convenience and anytime you
cooked it was French food and then in
the seventies and eighties it was this
explosion of world cuisines and we
learned about Mexican and not just
Mexican but well hawkin and food from
Veracruz and we learned about Italian
food and Italian food food,
but food from Ramon Emilia Romano and
from the glorious.
So,
um,
there's been this evolution of knowledge
and sophistication and it's all kind of
come back down into where the food from,
where you're from.
And even at the local board term has
only been coined two years ago in San
Francisco.
Um,
it makes a lot of sense.
I mean,
essentially what it is,
is a food will have movement that says
you should really,
your diet should really be consisting of
food that has been harvested or process
from within 100 mile radius of your
home.
And that makes a lot of sense because
you're sustaining the farmers.
You're eating food that is as nutrient
rich as possible.
You are contributing to the greening of
the planets by doing this and you're
helping small businesses grow in your
area.
So those are all very important points
and hopefully the food is organic.
Hopefully it's been harvested,
are processed in a really healthy green
way.
You are really thinking globally and
acting locally.
I mean it really is kind of the fruition
of that concept which was,
you know,
the in the last 10 years so that you're
really helping sustain your area and the
people that live within your radius.
So to me it makes a lot of sense and
it's the way that we,
we lived all those years ago and it,
in terms of health,
it makes the most sense for sure because
what it does is it forces you to eat in
a much more healthy manner.